dana white
to sell his remaining shares
uh of uh ufc two decades after buying it
for a couple million dollars is now
a seven seven billion who wrote this
article was one kid this is a euro
because it's pound
seven billion pounds which is what
roughly it's about a ten billion dollar
company
as tech mogul elon musk joins the board
of director
of ufc interesting they know what is
said to hand over his remaining shares
in ufc as parent company endeavor
prepares to take 100 control over this
company ufc dana white was installed as
the organization's president back in 20
2001 after his childhood friend
lorenzo fertitta and his brother frank
bought it for a couple million
dollars he cashed in when he sold a
chunk of his shares to endeavor in 2016
in a cell
for around three and a half billion
dollars endeavor conglomerate ran by
hollywood super agent ari emanuel that
last name emmanuel they produce
some players has already built up a
controlling stake of 50.1 percent of ufc
and now it wants to scoop up the rest
and another boost for endeavor tech
billionaire elon musk is now sitting
on their board what do you think about
the saddle i mean there's so much to
unpack in this story this is actually
the idea i had for you um because this
endeavor group is basically looking to
take the company public
this was an idea i had for you to do
maybe um a biz doc
episode um on whatever is going on here
with this endeavor group in ufc
i mean you go back 10 years ago
ufc wasn't even in the conversation as a
top sport
wasn't even the conversation i mean it's
not in the big three or the big four or
whatever
basketball football baseball hockey you
know soccer
track and field boxing certainly it was
a comedy brand yeah
and now ufc is certainly bigger than
boxing these days
boxing is so below ufc these days that
the biggest fights in boxing
are 50 year olds mike tyson versus roy
jones jr
or weigh-ins or weigh-ins or
freaking jake paul versus nate robinson
like that's how far
boxing has sunk versus ufc so and it all
kind of falls on dana white what he's
been able to do
and it started with a 1.5 million dollar
investment or 1.5 million
pounds which is probably closer to two
two million dollars
and now his 1.5 investment is worth what
seven billion what is that no no no not
his not dana white they know why cause
it's only ten percent
he has temperatures about eight billion
dollars and he sold some of his shares
and now he's gonna sell the rest so he
may have sold five percent of it
which for 175 million dollars now he's
gonna sell the other five percent for
probably 350 million dollars so he's
going to walk away he's going to
probably
with a half a billion dollars somewhere
i'm going to say he's between 500 to a
billion dollars is where he's at
500 to 750. so what the guy's a player
what do i say
a thousand time x's money where is he at
it's not even about a thousand times
excess money if if dana white wanted to
run for office
he's got that kind of swagger to want to
do whatever the hell he wants to do he's
daniel
he's told him he wouldn't do it because
he wants that freedom that he has
here's here's the thing with dana white
people don't realize uh dana white
let me just give this shout out to dana
what you can replace great fighters you
have to realize the ufc's had anderson
silva chocolate del tito these guys were
legends even some of the old school guys
gsp connor where's he at connor the diaz
brothers
there are so many incredible fighters be
like oh my gosh i enjoy watching this i
want to see another fight of this guy
great armenian fighter great mexican
randall
i mean randomly was from a different
league the point i'm trying to make to
you is
fighters have come and gone but there's
one guys that stuck around
and it's been dana white when you think
about ufc you think about one name
you think about dana white right they
got another they got a deep bench right
now of guys that could be the next day
in white
and their biggest challenge whoever buys
them endeavor
they have to make sure they keep their
dana white
look when boxing started take a hit
think about when boxing started to take
a hit
i got a guy that wants to be interviewed
on vitamin who was uh connected to the
mob and he was one of the biggest guys
when it came down to
boxing you know we were talking about
this guy you know
his pr publicist reached out to us where
they manipulated fights hey you
losing second round losing third round
because it's so many ways to make money
in boxing vegas makes so much money
gamblers make it's a dirty side of it as
well
right you don't hear that with ufc but
you hear that live with boxing
you know when boxing start started kind
of uh drifting and people stop following
it
when you no longer heard of a guy named
don king
okay people have to realize there is so
much value
in a don king there is where the don
king was replaced by a fighter
mayweather
that's bad news when the down king
becomes a fighter
because a fighter is eventually going to
what stop fighting
the career of a promoter is longer than
the career of a what
a fighter so especially peak right so
if if whoever endeavor you know endeavor
comes in here takes you know dana
white's rest of the shares out because
they want to be 100
they better give this guy a fat salary
with a nice profit sharing and some
you know additional bonuses because the
guy's done a great job
or slowly but surely you better start
getting that bench set up of the next 10
12 guys that can potentially be to dana
white
somebody that's a true believer in it
and see what happens with it
bodybuilding mr olympia you know why
bodybuilding with olympia has been dying
out
why because nobody's replacing joe
weeder everybody's trying to be joe
weeder no one's replacing joe weeder
even the guy that we had on uh
valuetainment we interviewed him
who was one of the greatest promoters of
all time like literally one of the
greatest
promoters of all time oh man i cannot
believe i'm missing him um uh
you know you go back and you look at
even
wayne emilia phenomenal interview i
really enjoy talking to wayne the
stories he told
all the things that he did promoters are
very valuable
whoever is buying this you better have a
deep bench
of someone with dana white tendencies
i agree exactly what you're saying and
what you're talking about is the forward
brand of a company
here's what's going on here so the two
brothers buy this let's think of that as
the venture capital stage for ufc
million and a half dollars seed funding
pretty damn big seed
uh and all they go then endeavour buys
it in 16
for three billion big chunk that they
buy there was probably a three year earn
out on that and the earn out is hey this
has to keep going this can't crash you
have to stay involved over three years
well that would be 2019 then we roll
into the coveted year of 2020.
now they want to buy the rest of it and
potentially take it public
so what they're trying to do here is
consolidate all the stock so that they
can take it public without complication
and that's what endeavor wants to do
endeavor is a talent agency i hope
they're listening to what pat just said
because you need a face of the brand to
go forward
this is a mechanical move to consolidate
the stock get ready for an ipo take it
forward that's great everybody can
invest in it
wall street bets can talk about it but
if they don't have the face of the brand
then guess what they've got apple
without steve jobs and
that's not going to work you need a face
of the brand
based on this you know you you need
larry ellison at oracle you needed steve
jobs here you needed gates
and microsoft there are faces that are
that are they're out there by the way
that they're listening to the brand the
link to the brand gates was a geek
linked to microsoft you know jobs was a
brilliant designer with product instinct
tom linked to the brand would you give
credit to gates for who he replaced
himself with
yes i would okay i would yes i would but
balmer
are you kidding me the guy
the amount of credit gates gives to him
don't get me wrong they bump heads and
it's not like a best friend relationship
that they had
but you know what balmer did to
microsoft yes you know what tim cook did
to apple i mean
you gotta so so i just hope they find
the right guy
replacing dana white that's a true
believer that's all i'm saying you think
they actually
they understand this like 100 percent 10
billion dollars without understanding
they get this they know exactly what i'm
talking about they're not you know
dummies no no not at all they know it
but sometimes
sometimes you when you make a choice
like this you can't
choose someone you like that's right
sometimes you choose someone you like
you have to choose the right person that
can do the job and you typically don't
like
bill gates doesn't love bomber he's the
right guy for it
and they have to get right back can you
imagine how like you think about dana
white what do you think dana white's
like to have somebody that's
reporting to you to his board he's a
handful can you imagine dana white
coming in
well let me give you guys an update of
what's going on with our numbers no
imagine dana white in the boardroom i'm
so i can't believe he throw that
through the window and these mother
and we're gonna go after the oscar
that's who he is now the first thing is
hey dana's an hour wait again for the
board meeting are we having this board
meeting what are we doing here
you know where is this guy is he coming
here are we doing business today
say something you know because he's the
guy
that knows how to steer the pot and
that's that's exactly right the sea
letter award the sexy sea letter word of
today's podcast
oh my gosh competition competition baby
it's so sexy research and competition
competition
is so flipping sexy by the way
if you're listening you agree you
disagree
i love it either way comment below but
if you're enjoying the podcast
smash that thumbs up button and if you
think you're already a subscriber you
may not be because this is a completely
different channel
click that subscribe button and the
notification button so you will be
uh notified the next time we go live
with our podcast i have one point one
last point here
i want everybody to look at ufc and go
take a look at this
and look at who are their main big
sponsors like the official soda the
official beer
look at all those look at the money to
give to ufc
do you think the nfl mlb major league
baseball nba do you think they want
those dollars they sure do
and so there's also a side of this that
they're competing for corporate dollars
for all the eyeballs of the young men
and women that love the brand and dana
white
is a magnet that makes that happen
there's that c word again
competition all right i feel like
monster's the biggest sponsor of ufc i
just
properly 12 probably not it's probably
monster but proper 12 would be
a billion dollar i mean mcgregor yeah i
mean i know you're helping i gotta tell
you man there is something
do you think the other sports want those
dollars absolutely they do
who wants a dollar the other sports want
those dollars there is no face of base
basketball right they had to make it
lebron
the product is the face lebron is an
iphone 11. someday
lebron will be replaced by somebody else
he's a heck of a heck of an iphone but
the point is there's no face of the nba
the players are the face of the nba dana
white is the face the passion the future
the rudder of ufc
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
you